what was running through your head as
you heard the judgment
well it is disappointing but the fact
that the eight individual claimants have
all had their cases blocked means that
there are a lot of problems with this
policy and there are ways that we can
continue to fight it so we will be
discussing with our lawyers how we take
this forward
um this is just the first court to hear
this case so it is by no means over and
hopefully we will be continuing to fight
this I think that the prime minister is
wrong to say this is an important part
of the fight against migration because
we all know this policy is not going to
act as a deterrent since it was
introduced Channel Crossings have
reached an all-time high people have
continued to cross and anyone who's
spoken to people in Calais will tell you
this is not stopping them getting in
small boats it's not going to achieve
anything so you know when we know this
is not going to stop Small Boat
Crossings why are we looking at
something that is so incredibly brutal
and that does risk breaking our
International obligations under
International treaties and the point
that you make is important about those
eight individuals because you yes the
court found today that the policy is
lawful but they also found that when it
came to those eight individuals the Home
Secretary hadn't properly considered
their circumstances so it's being
referred back to I said is there the
potential that for every individual we
could see this the government being
taken through the courts and actually in
practice it's not workable the policy
yes there really is and um and we
certainly would back every single
individual who wants to fight their case
and we would be helping them all to find
lawyers because this is an incredibly
important case
um the impact on the individuals I can't
tell you last time they tried to have a
fight we were helping 130 of those
individuals and I was speaking to them
to their families to their wives to
their to the to their children to their
mothers I had people on the phone to me
begging me there was one gentleman he
has two young sons and he was saying to
me I feel like I have let my family down
because I will be abandoning my sons in
the world on their own those children
were saying to me please don't let my
father be put on that plane to Rwanda I
will never see him again people were so
trauma at the thought of being centered
around I can't tell you they were
threatening suicide they were
self-harming this is so important we
have to fight for every single
individual and I'm just so glad that it
does look like there will be the ability
to do that